first of all tell me about this outfit  this is epic this is actually fetch - no  but I have yeah have you met cardi  before well tonight the first time and  what do you love most about her what  inspires the attitude cardi is one of my  favorite few more ever I know that  you're actually turning 16 next year are  you getting that driver's license you  don't want to drive by my job and I hit  somebody's car oh my god okay no they  weren't in the car over the hit okay  okay pick it up we figured that yeah  okay what are you working on right now  my album help one isn't gonna drop what  can you tell me are beginning to car D  collab on the album are you worth Harvey  have you talked to her about it  doing features all right we'll have fun  tonight  [Music]